okay so i love that he thought that your  accent was fake because this film was it  was it based in texas is that what it  yeah yeah okay so you had an american  accent  and you just kept that all the time  i guess i kept it around him and then  and then he thought you were  like bsing him and like like why are you  speaking with a british accent to me i  guess i mean i don't remember keeping it  all the time but i i did sometimes and i  guess i did when i was around  steve martin for some reason and then um  yeah got to like press day a few months  you know like a year later and he was  like ah  you're english  i mean job well done like he had no idea  that's amazing you're really good at  accents it went down well i just loved  it like a year later after filming wait  you're british  it's a lot of missed moments there but  anyway  [Music]  you